Coffee on a Tuesday in blog,
31.
Ooh,
yeah,
so did you see this new Google video
floating around?
Project glass in which all the
information that you can access on your
smartphone is put into these very sleek
glasses and made a part of your regular
vision.
That surprised me,
that Google put this ad out because it
must mean they think that there are more
people who would see this and say,
wow,
that's amazing.
I want that.
Then those who would almost reflexively
be terrified by it.
The video was shot in first person so as
to put the viewer in the experience,
and I wonder if I was the only one who
felt a palpable sense of intrusion when
the first icons launched into the whole
add functions as a sort of metaphor for
social media.
Something that is wedging its way into
our lives and the culture is so
successfully that we can't help but to
participate in it with everyone else.
This is the effect of all new
technologies they create needs that you
did not have before needs,
which you can abstain from satisfying or
even recognizing,
but only until they apply to that
critical mass of people at that point
not to use the technology actually puts
you at a disadvantage in communication.
People begin to get angry with you,
right,
and you're all but forced to conform.
Think of cell phones.
You can choose not to have one,
but are you willing to suffer the
frustration and displeasure of all those
who feel entitled to get in touch with
you at any time?
You can cling to your principles,
but what happens when those principles
come into tension with relationships?
You're not willing to compromise.
You may say you don't want to be friends
with anyone who doesn't respect your
choice,
not to be plugged in.
That might work today with facebook and
twitter,
but not really anymore with cell phones,
right?
What job today doesn't require you to
have a cell phone?
have a smartphone?
It's in this way that technology's wedge
themselves into the culture.
Over time.
Individually,
you may disagree with the technology,
but you like everyone else has a stake
in culture,
so as far as the culture accepts
facebook,
twitter,
cell phones,
smartphones,
et Cetera,
you will have to compromise your values
to the extent that you want to
participate in it.
We're all pulled along.
By the way,
the culture.
Maybe tomorrow you decide that you'll
never watch a youtube video again,
but you can't be someone who never
watched a youtube video,
no doubt it's a terrifying prospect and
you're not human if you don't feel even
a little bit overwhelmed by cultural
changes of this nature and even more
overwhelmed when you realize that the
changes are coming at an accelerating
rate and devices like the Google glasses
will be ubiquitous,
not tomorrow or next year,
but in a relatively short time.
You begin to wonder who decides what
comes next.
In the postwar fifties and sixties,
manufacturers created dozens and dozens
of new appliances for the growing number
of middle class homes,
appliances that they perhaps didn't
need,
but a capitalist economy is structured
toward growth toward corporations needed
to build and create new products for
consumption.
You see the same trend today in
technology and social media.
The differences that in the past it was
physical products that you could put
somewhere the advances in upgrades in
tech instead have the effect of small,
gradual,
unsolicited alterations to our
personalities and that's weird.
There's a lot of literature out there
already on the way the Internet age is
affecting our minds and social behavior.
Many say that it's a boon connecting us
to more people and more information.
Others say that social media only gives
the illusion of being more connected
when in fact we are more separated and
alone.
There is truth to both.
I'm sure,
and this is only the first chapter in a
long story,
but this weekend I had the pleasure to
take a trip to the beautiful desert east
of Los Angeles and sitting there among
the sparse vegetation decompressing
after 30 weeks of Lugs,
I had the feeling that social media
doesn't so much corrupt.
Our ability to be social as it does our
ability to be alone,
to savor that much needed solitude and
silence in which so many things are
reconciled and put in their proper
place.
And maybe it's this condition of
perpetual half measures,
half alone,
half together,
all the time that we should be most
careful to guard against,
if not for the culture at large.
Then at least for ourselves,
from the first and biggest drop off the
top of the jar.
So far,
happy faces at all times.
Peter Pan,
peanut butter on.